This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. For most of his life, Sam Anderson didn't think about Oklahoma City much at all. Sam is a journalist. He lived in New York City for a long time, and Oklahoma City just wasn't on his radar. But then, in 2012, he was assigned to do a story about the Oklahoma City Thunder. The city's new basketball team had just gone to the NBA finals. And they had this amazing trio of young stars, Kevin Durant, Russell Westbrook, and James Hardin.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。萨姆·安德森大半辈子都没怎么想过俄克拉荷马城。萨姆是一位记者。他在纽约市住了很长时间，俄克拉荷马城根本不在他的关注范围内。但后来，在2012年，他被指派去写一篇关于俄克拉荷马城雷霆队的报道。这座城市的新篮球队刚刚打进了NBA总决赛。他们拥有凯文·杜兰特、拉塞尔·威斯布鲁克和詹姆斯·哈登这三位令人惊叹的年轻球星。
They were all really different players with really different temperaments and styles, but there was something kind of magical and unstoppable about the way they played together. Final second Durant got a good look at the three, and they make you pay. They set that up so beautifully. So Sam got on a plane and as he was flying to Oklahoma City to meet the guys and to ride about their team, he was reading a book about the history of Oklahoma to get more familiar with the place. And it was talking about the origin of tornadoes and it was saying that tornadoes
他们都是非常不同的球员，有着非常不同的气质和风格，但他们在一起打球的方式有一种神奇且不可阻挡的力量。最后时刻，杜兰特看准了三分球的机会，他们让你付出了代价。他们的配合太精彩了。于是萨姆坐上飞机，在飞往俄克拉荷马城去见这些球员并报道他们的球队时，他正在读一本关于俄克拉荷马历史的书，以便更熟悉这个地方。书中谈到了龙卷风的起源，并说龙卷风
are caused by this collision of three separate very different weather forces. You've got kind of dry air coming from the desert. You've got this cold Arctic air coming down from Canada and you've got this warm, heavy hot Gulf air coming from the South. And they all collide over Oklahoma in a way that those forces don't collide really anywhere else in the world. And at that moment Sam had a realization and he wrote it down in the margin of the book, Harden Durant Westbrook, which was the three big basketball stars on the thunder who were
是由三种截然不同的天气力量碰撞而成的。你有来自沙漠的干空气，有从加拿大南下的寒冷北极空气，还有从南方吹来的温暖、沉重且潮湿的墨西哥湾空气。它们在俄克拉荷马州上空以一种世界上其他任何地方都不会发生的方式碰撞。就在那一刻，萨姆顿悟了，他在书的页边空白处写下了“哈登、杜兰特、威斯布鲁克”，也就是雷霆队的三大篮球明星，他们
a similar trio of strangely clashing forces that basketball had never really seen before. So in that little leap, like I was noticing these thematic echoes between things about the history of Oklahoma and things about the basketball team and the kind of civics of the modern city. Sam started seeing these kinds of connections everywhere. The history of Oklahoma City started to seem so interwoven with the contemporary life of the place in these fascinating and unexpected ways that he decided he wanted to write a whole book about it. Not just about the basketball team,
就像是篮球界从未见过的、奇怪而冲突的三股力量。所以在那一瞬间，我注意到俄克拉荷马的历史与篮球队以及现代城市公民生活之间存在着主题上的呼应。萨姆开始在各处看到这种联系。俄克拉荷马城的历史开始以一种迷人且意想不到的方式与当地的当代生活交织在一起，以至于他决定要写一本关于它的书。不仅仅是关于篮球队，
but about the city itself, from its founding, which was a really very weird event, to the present day. The book is called Boomtown, and it's one of my favorite things I've read in the past year. I think it'll go down to history as one of the great pieces of narrative nonfiction, actually. So today, we're dedicating the entire episode to my conversation with Sam. There are so many interesting chapters and anecdotes in this book, but I wanted to focus
而是关于这座城市本身，从它那非常离奇的建城事件，一直到今天。这本书叫《繁荣之城》（Boomtown），是我过去一年读过的最喜欢的书之一。事实上，我认为它将作为叙事非虚构文学的伟大作品之一载入史册。所以今天，我们将整期节目献给我与萨姆的对话。这本书里有太多有趣的章节和轶事，但我只想重点关注
primarily on the insane fountain of Oklahoma City, in an event that's known as the Land Run of 1889. To understand that story, you have to go back just a little bit further to earlier in the 1800s, when Oklahoma wasn't even a state yet It was a place known as Indian territory and the US government was kind of using it as this spot on the Great Plains that it could force Indigenous peoples into to make room for American settlers as they took over the country so
俄克拉荷马城那疯狂的起源，即被称为“1889年土地大抢购”的事件。要理解那个故事，你必须回到19世纪早期，那时俄克拉荷马甚至还不是一个州。它被称为“印第安领地”，美国政府把它当作大平原上的一个地方，可以强行将原住民赶到那里，以便在他们接管国家时为美国定居者腾出空间，所以
You had dozens of tribes that were forced into there all the trails of led to Oklahoma. So that's what it was in the 1800s. Then during the Civil War, a couple of tribes in Indian territory made alliances with the south rather than the north, and as punishment after the war, the federal government stripped them of their land. This left an enormous patch of unoccupied space right in the middle of the territory. Roughly half the size of Connecticut. So it's a fairly big space, and suddenly it just had nobody in it.
你有几十个部落被强行赶到那里，所有的道路都通向俄克拉荷马。这就是19世纪的情况。后来在内战期间，印第安领地里的几个部落与南方而不是北方结盟，作为战后的惩罚，联邦政府剥夺了他们的土地。这在领地中部留下了一大片无人居住的空地。大约有康涅狄格州的一半大。所以这是一个相当大的空间，突然之间就没人了。
And everybody referred to this patch of Indian territory as the unassigned lands. In the 1860s and 70s, white settlers from the surrounding areas like Kansas and Texas started making illegal raids into the unassigned lands. In the 1860s and 70s, white settlers from the surrounding areas, like Kansas and Texas, started making illegal raids into the unassigned lands to try to seize it as their own. And the leader of this group, known as the Boomers, was a guy named David Paine. Yeah, so David Paine was apparently this incredibly charismatic guy. I mean, the pictures of him, he's quite striking, he's really intense eyes in this kind of beautiful hair.
每个人都把这片印第安领地称为“未分配土地”。在19世纪60年代和70年代，来自堪萨斯州和德克萨斯州等周边地区的白人定居者开始非法突袭“未分配土地”，试图将其据为己有。在19世纪60年代和70年代，来自堪萨斯州和德克萨斯州等周边地区的白人定居者开始非法突袭“未分配土地”，试图将其据为己有。这个被称为“繁荣者”（Boomers）的团体的领导人是一个叫大卫·佩恩的人。是的，大卫·佩恩显然是一个非常有魅力的人。我是说，看他的照片，他非常引人注目，眼神非常犀利，还有那种漂亮的头发。
He looks like he could be an indie singer or something, you know, playing a banjo and wooing young girls. So, you know, he would ride around Kansas and get up on a wagon and he would shout out these speeches to these struggling farmers about how there was this patch of America that belonged to the American people, but the government wouldn't let them have it. And he managed to convince many, many, many people to buy into his vision of Oklahoma as this
他看起来就像个独立歌手之类的，你知道，弹着班卓琴，吸引年轻女孩。所以，他会骑马在堪萨斯州到处跑，站上马车，对着那些挣扎的农民大声演讲，说美国有一片属于美国人民的土地，但政府不让他们拥有。他成功说服了许多许多人相信他关于俄克拉荷马的愿景，将其视为
kind of sacred holy land for white settlers in the middle of Indian territory. In this is the beginning of the scheme that was the land run, which you talk about is being the craziest way that a city could possibly have been born. So could you describe what are the kind of the ground rules of the land run and how did it start Oklahoma City? Yeah, so modern historians looking back, basically all agree that this was the worst way
印第安领地中间为白人定居者准备的某种神圣土地。这就是“土地大抢购”计划的开始，你称之为城市诞生最疯狂的方式。那么你能描述一下土地大抢购的基本规则，以及它是如何开启俄克拉荷马城的吗？是的，现代历史学家回顾过去，基本上都同意这是开启一座城市最糟糕的方式。即使在这些限制条件下，它也进行得非常糟糕。所以真的没有多少规则。我是说，政府最终说，是的，好吧，你们可以拥有未分配土地。任何想要一块土地的人，我们要怎么做？来在未分配土地的边界排队。这是一个300英里长的圆周。在大多数地方它没有标记。有标记的地方，也就是一堆石头或一条小溪之类的。所以请在1889年4月22日在这条边界排队。中午时分，我们会发出信号，
you could ever start a city. And even within those confines, I went very poorly. So there really were not many rules. I mean, so the government finally says, yes, all right, you can have the onesign lands. Anybody who wants a piece of it, who's what we're going to do? Come line up at the border of the Anasine lands. This is a 300 mile long circumference. In most places it's not marked. Where it is marked, it's like a stack of rocks or a creek or something. So come line up around this border on April 22nd, 1889. And at noon, we will give a signal
然后任何想要这片土地的人都可以冲进去，钉下木桩，宣称拥有这片领地。如果你在乡下，你可以拥有160英亩。如果你在指定的城镇地点，你可以拥有该城镇地点较小的一块。基本上就是这样。即使是这些基本规则也很惊人，因为在1889年，谁来决定什么是中午？
and anybody who wants some of this land can rush in and hammer down some wooden stakes and claim some of this territory. If you're out in the country, you can have 160 acres. If you're in what's been designated a town site, you can have a smaller patch of that town site. And that's pretty much it. Even the basics of this is amazing because who decides what noon is in 1889?
你知道我的意思吗？是的，没错。没有标准化的原子钟之类的东西。你知道，他们无法发出数字精确的信号。所以人们必须自己判断什么是中午。来自世界各地的人们都来了，这引发了全球范围内的一场真正的运动。欧洲有人来到利物浦和汉堡，乘船前往俄克拉荷马。有人在芝加哥和纽约的主要报纸上刊登分类广告，
You know what I'm saying? Yeah right, right. There's not like a standardized atomic clock somewhere. You know, they can set off a digital precise signal. So people had to kind of figure out for themselves what noon was. And people came from all over the world, this set off like a real movement around the globe. You had people in Europe like coming to Liverpool and coming to Hamburg to like ship out to get to Oklahoma. You had people putting classified ads in major newspapers
说让我们聚在一起，结成联盟，制定计划，去俄克拉荷马抢占土地。在那一天，大约有10万人出现在边界排队，准备冲进去。所以，中午到了，对不同的人来说时间可能不同，毕竟有300英里的边界。接下来发生了什么？所以中午到了，所谓的“中午”。在某些地方，有士兵发出信号，所以每个人都必须等待。在北部，士兵们拉起了一根长绳子。
in Chicago and New York to let's meet up and form an alliance and make a plan and go to Oklahoma and claim some land. And for the day itself, you had something like 100,000 people show up to line up at the border and make a run for it. So, noon strikes, maybe at different times for different people, like lot of 300-mile border. What happens next? So noon strikes, quote-unquote noon. And in some places, there are soldiers giving the signal, so everyone has to wait. Up north, the soldiers have this long rope that they've pulled across.
边界的一部分，人们被挡在后面；在南部，有一条河，人们骑在马上，坐在河中间，陷在流沙里，等待信号。然后在某些情况下，他们鸣枪，在某些情况下，他们吹响号角，然后他们就出发了。你有富人、穷人，骑着家庭马车的，有骑着前一天刚买的赛马的，有骑着家庭马车的，有骑着前一天刚买的赛马的，
Part of the border, the people are held behind, down south, there's a river that people are sitting on their horses, like in the middle of the river, sort of sinking in quicksand, waiting for the signal. And then in some cases they fired guns, in some cases they blew a bugle and they were off. And you had, you know, rich people, poor people, people riding the family wagon, you had people on race horses that they had just bought like the day before, you had people riding the family wagon, you had people on race horses that they just bought like
有骑着破骡子的，有骑自行车的，有步行的，他们就这样冲过边界，开始比赛。这片土地很崎岖，到处都是干涸的河床，还有水牛打滚留下的水牛坑。这些马车立刻开始撞上车辙，直接散架了。我是说，这些车辆根本不是为了高速在崎岖路面上行驶而设计的。所以这些车辆散架了，
the day before, you had people riding broken down mules, there were people on bicycles, there were people on foot, and they just burst across the border and start racing. And this land is rough, it's like, I mean, they're dry creek beds all over it, they're buffalo wallows, we're buffalo roll around. And immediately these wagons start hitting these ruts and just busting apart. I mean, these are not vehicles intended for rough riding at high speeds. So these vehicles are busting apart
人们从车里飞出来，在草原上翻滚，然后爬起来继续向前跑。这太疯狂了。我是说，人们为了让马跑得更快而鸣枪，结果不小心射中了彼此。马匹因精疲力竭而死。我认为这是你能想象到的最狂野的场景。
and people are flying out of them and rolling across the prairie and getting up and running forward. It's just wild. I mean, people are shooting guns to speed up their horses and accidentally shooting each other. Horses are dying of exhaustion. I think it's just about the wildest scene you can imagine.
而那些真正作弊的人，也就是在中午之前就开始的人，让情况变得更加复杂，他们最初被嘲讽地称为“抢先者”（Sooners）。即使在今天，“抢先者”仍然是俄克拉荷马现代神话的一部分。是的，没错。我是说，如果你在俄克拉荷马，你会经常听到“繁荣者”和“抢先者”这两个词。如果你去参加大学橄榄球比赛，人群会来回呼喊。
And this is complicated even more by the people who really cheated, who started way before noon, and they became known pretty derisively at first as the Sooners. And the Sooners are still part of the modern day mythology of Oklahoma even today. Yeah, right. I mean, Boomer and Sooner are words that you'll hear a lot if you're in Oklahoma. If you go to a college football game, it's actually a thing that the crowd yells back and forth.
“繁荣者，抢先者，繁荣者，抢先者”。没错，俄克拉荷马大学橄榄球队实际上就叫“抢先者队”。这是一种俄克拉荷马人真正拥抱的身份认同。“繁荣者！”你知道，你会在手机铃声里听到这个。所以，是的，俄克拉荷马的身份认同中确实有一条主线。所以“繁荣者”是那些为开放未分配土地而奔走的人。
Boomer, Sooner, Boomer, Sooner. Right. The University of Oklahoma football team is actually called the Sooners. football game, it's actually a thing that the crowd yells back and forth, boomer, sooner, boomer, sooner. Right, the University of Oklahoma football team is actually called the Sooners. It's this identity that Oklahoma's really embraced it. Boomer! You know, you'll hear that like on ringtones and people's phones and stuff. So, yeah, there is a real through line in the identity of Oklahoma's. So the boomers were the ones who agitated for the opening of the unassigned lands.
“抢先者”是那些在土地大抢购日期最终确定后，设法作弊的人。他们中很多人恰好也是“繁荣者”，因为“繁荣者”觉得他们对这片土地有特别的权利，因为是他们做了工作才让政府允许他们进入。所以他们有点怨恨那些最后一刻才出现的人。
Sooners were people who, when the date of the land run was finally set, managed to cheat. A lot of them happened to be boomers as well, because the boomers felt particularly entitled to this land, because they're the ones who did the work to get the government to allow them in. So they kind of resented all these other people who were just showing up the last minute.
所以他们想出了各种作弊方法。我是说，有故事说有个热气球驾驶员在中午之前就在俄克拉荷马上空盘旋，这样当号角吹响时，他就能直接降落在自己最喜欢的地点。我是说，有许多许多营地的人躲在沟壑和小溪边，这些“抢先者”营地在土地大抢购前的几周里，联邦军队会来驱散他们，然后他们又会重新聚集。威廉·库奇，在大卫·佩恩死后接管了“繁荣者”运动，
So they found all kinds of ways to cheat. I mean, there were stories of like a hot air balloonist hovering over Oklahoma just before noon so that he could just touch down on his favorite spot when the bugle was blown. I mean, there were many, many, many camps of people who were hiding out in these kind of gullies and along creeks, these kind of sooner camps that the federal troops would come through and disperse in the weeks leading up to the land run and then they would reassemble. William Couch, who had taken over the boomer movement
是主要的作弊者之一，他与铁路公司关系密切。所以他和他的商界亲信实际上多次进入。有一张令人难以置信的照片，他和他的一个合伙人站在现在的俄克拉荷马城市中心，当时那里在土地大抢购前一个月还是一片绝对空旷、长满灌木的草地，规划着他们想要的城市样子。所以，当信号发出时，理论上人们应该需要一个多小时才能到达，因为距离最近的边界有15英里，然而就在号角吹响的那一刻，
when David Payne died, was one of the main cheaters and he was deeply connected to the railroads And so he and his businessmen cronies Actually went in many times. There's this incredible picture of him and one of his associates standing In what is now downtown Oklahoma City and was just then this absolute empty scrubby grass prairie a month before the landrun Mapping out how they wanted the city to look. And so, when the signal is given, theoretically it should have taken people maybe an hour plus to get there because it was 15 miles from the closest border, and yet the moment the
你看到人们，包括威廉·库奇和他的亲信，从灌木丛中跳出来，从火车车厢里跳出来，从树上掉下来。这就像一个神话般的起源故事，人们突然从景观中出现。士兵们不知道该怎么办，因为人太多了，他们到处搭帐篷、钉木桩。威廉·库奇和他的团队有一整队测量员，
bugle blew, you had people, including William Couch and his cronies, leaping out of the bushes, jumping out of train cars, falling out of trees. It's like this mythological origin story where people just suddenly appear out of the landscape. And the soldiers don't know what to do, because there's so many of them, and they're just planting tents all over and hammering stakes. And William Couch and his crew have a whole team of surveyors
带着他们的设备、链条和杆子，按照他们在土地大抢购前几个月绘制的地图，铺设街道和地块。然后，在此之后将俄克拉荷马变成一个真正的地方，部分工作就是裁决所有这些作弊行为。谁作弊了，谁没作弊？谁有权保留他们的土地，谁没有？因为他们作为定居者定居在这片土地上，而不是作为城市建设者。他们并没有考虑到让城市正常运转的因素。他们真的只是为了自己的私人用途划分了自己的土地。
who have all their equipment, their chains and poles and everything, and they're laying out streets and lots as they have mapped it in the months preceding the land run. And then part of the labor of making Oklahoma into a real place after this was adjudicating all of that cheating. Who cheated and who didn't? Who deserved to keep their land and who didn't, who deserved to keep their land, and who didn't. Because they settled the land as settlers, not as city builders exactly. Like they didn't account for the things that make a city function. They really just plotted out their own land
是的，这在某种程度上是一个很好的隐喻，关于美国实验，美国人的气质。因为没错，你有一大波人涌入。我是说，四面八方的浪潮。每个人想的都是，我得拿到属于我的那份。我得在这个地方扎根，这样无论未来如何，我都能拥有我的一份。
for their own private use. Yeah, it's such a nice little metaphor in a way for, I don't know, the American experiment, the American temperament. Because exactly, you had this huge wave of people rushing in. I mean, waves from all sides. And what everyone was thinking about was, I need to get mine. I got to anchor down in this place so that whatever comes of it, I'll have my piece of
所以没有中央规划，没有任何远见。因此，到第一天结束时，在后来成为俄克拉荷马城的土地上，大约有1万名定居者，他们几乎占领了每一块土地。我是说，他们就像是，几乎是帐篷挨着帐篷，
it. So there was no central planning, there was no foresight whatsoever. And so by the end of the day on the site that would become Oklahoma City, you had something like 10,000 settlers and they had claimed pretty much every single patch of land. I mean, they were like, it was just like tent flap to tent flap almost,
你没有任何城市运作所需的负空间。你没有街道，没有小巷。除了城市中被这些作弊者规划出的部分，他们设法出售了他们规划出的土地上的地块证书。但除此之外，它只是一个巨大的、绝对的混乱，未来根本无法作为人类居住的地方运作。所以这大批涌入的人都占领了土地的不同部分，这是俄克拉荷马城成立的第一天。那天晚上发生了什么？所以你得到了这股令人难以置信的混乱人潮。他们都设法占领了一个点。现在在某些
and you didn't have any of the negative space that you really need for a city to work. You didn't have streets, you didn't have alleys. Other than the part of the city that had been mapped out by these cheaters, and they managed to sell certificates to own lots on the land that they had plotted out. But otherwise, it was just a giant absolute mess that could never going forward function as a place where humans live. So this huge influx of people all claimed different parts of the land, and this is on day one of the founding of Oklahoma City. What happens that first night? So you get this incredible chaotic rush of people. They all managed to claim a spot. Now in some
地方，你知道，有五个不同的定居者声称他们先到。所以你有各种纠纷，各种活动。当那天晚上太阳落山时，你得到了一种普遍的放松。每个人都停止了争夺地块。每个人都停止了工作。人们放松下来，环顾四周，休息。同样，因为这事发生得太近了，我们有所有这些目击者的记录。我们有新闻报道。
spots, you know, there's there's five separate settlers claiming that they were there first. So you have all these disputes, all kinds of activity. When the sun sets that night, you get this kind of general relaxation. Everybody stops jockeying for plots. Everyone stops their work. People kind of relax and look around and rest. And again, because this was so recent, we have all these eyewitness accounts. We have news accounts.
现场有记者。所以我们知道一些事情，比如到处都有蜈蚣在爬，因为整个生态系统显然因为人类毫无理由的注入而受到了惊吓。所以你看到了一个令人难以置信的场景，视野所及之处全是帐篷，一大群从未到过这个地方的新人，他们中的大多数人，
There were reporters on the ground. So we know things like there were centipedes crawling around everywhere because of course the whole ecosystem has just been shocked into agitation by this injection of humans into it for no reason. And so you have this incredible scene of just tense as far as you can see, masses of brand new people who've never been to this place before, most of them, most of whom have
彼此之间根本没有任何联系。那天晚上最突出的一个故事是，大约在晚上10点或午夜，说法略有不同。非常安静，然后一个声音突然打破了沉默，那是一个男人的声音。他是一个非常、非常强壮、响亮、低沉的声音。他喊出的内容在夜空中非常清晰，
no connection to one another at all. And the one story that really stands out from that first night was sometime around 10 PM or midnight accounts very a little bit. It's quite a down, and then a voice suddenly calls out into the silence, and it's a man's voice. He's a really, really strong, loud, low voice. And what he calls out is very clear in the night air,
但也完全令人费解。他说：“哦，乔，这是你的骡子。”每个人都环顾四周。关于这意味着什么有各种故事。这可能指的是一首古老的南方邦联歌曲，或者营地里的人在谈论那天晚上真正发生的事情。有一个叫乔的人在邻近的地块，
but also totally inscrutable. And he says, oh, Joe, here's your mule. And everybody kind of looks around. They're very stories about what that means. It might have been a reference to an old Confederate song, or maybe the people in the camp were talking about a thing that actually happened that night. There was a guy named Joe with a neighboring lot,
他的骡子走丢了，这个人找到了它。但发生的事情比它起源的原因更有趣，因为几秒钟之内，另一个声音呼应了那个声音。它说：“哦，乔，这是你的骡子。”然后有人呼应它。然后又有人。很快它就变成了一个绝对离奇的派对，
and his mule had wandered off, and this guy found it. But what happens is more interesting than whatever started it, because within a few seconds, another voice echoes that one. It says, oh Joe, here's your mule. And then somebody else echoes it. And then somebody else. And soon it turns into this like absolute bizarre party
俄克拉荷马城的所有人都在互相大喊：“哦，乔，这是你的骡子”，一遍又一遍。它在整个城镇上空回荡。他们说实际上声音太大了，以至于驻扎在离那里大约一英里外过夜的联邦军队也听到了。他们也开始回喊。然后城外的定居者也听到了。他们也开始喊。所以你只是有一群人喊着“哦，乔，这是你的骡子”的喧闹声。有些人说那天晚上它从一个定居者传到另一个定居者，一直传到100英里外北部的堪萨斯州边界，也就是整个混乱开始的地方。
of everybody in Oklahoma City shouting, oh Joe, here's your mule over and over and over again at one another. And it's just resonating over the whole town site. And they say actually it was so loud that the federal troops who were stationed about a mile away for the night heard it. And they started calling it back to. And then settlers on the outside of town heard it. And they started calling it out too. And so you just have this cacophony of people shouting, oh, Joe, here's your mule. And some people say that it's spread that night from settler to settler all the way 100 miles north back to the Kansas line where this whole mess had begun.
所以，是的，那是第一晚。这就是你所说的所有定居者第一次成为一个城镇的时刻。是的，我是说，从心理上讲，很难让自己身临其境，但这一定是每个人一生中最疯狂的一天。他们忍受了各种苦难、饥饿、干渴和恐惧。每个人都全副武装，每个人都在争吵，你不知道你得到的是好地块还是坏地块，你的马车坏了，
So yeah, that was the first night. And this is kind of the moment that you cite is when all the settlers kind of become a town for the first time. Yeah, I mean psychologically, it's hard to put yourself there, but it's got to be the craziest day of everyone's life. And they've endured all kinds of hardship, hunger and thirst and terror. Everyone is armed to the teeth and everyone's arguing and you don't know if you're getting a good spot or a bad spot and you're wagon broke
你差点摔断胳膊，等等等等。然后突然在晚上，你得到了这种奇怪的集体体验，几乎就像是一起唱歌之类的，你知道？所以所有这些彼此完全无关的人，刚刚在这股自私的浪潮中来到这个陌生的地方，突然参与了这种社区觉醒。我觉得那一定是一种极其强烈的
and you almost broke your arm and et cetera, et cetera. And then suddenly at night you get this bizarre sort of communal, it's almost like a sing-along or something, you know? And yeah, so all these people who are completely unrelated to one another, who have just arrived at this new and strange place in this kind of tidal wave of selfishness, you know, are suddenly participating in this community awakening. And I feel like that must have been this incredibly intense
联结体验，开始帮助这群非常奇怪的人成为一个真正的集体，他们将继续前进并成为一个真正的城市。在“哦，乔”事件之后，在俄克拉荷马城存在的第二天，出现了两位不同的领导人。一个是威廉·库奇，他是“抢先者”的实际领导人，也被称为“作弊者”。他为了通过在城市的一部分出售土地证书来中饱私囊而进行了策划和阴谋。然后是安杰洛·斯科特，他在土地大抢购期间来到俄克拉荷马。
bonding experience that started to help this very strange collection of people become an actual collective who would go forward and become a real city. After the Ojo incident, on the second day of Oklahoma City's existence, two different leaders emerged. There was William Couch, who was the de facto leader of the Sooners, also known as the Cheaters. He had plotted and schemed in order to enrich himself by selling land certificates in this one part of the city. And then there was Angelo Scott, who had come to Oklahoma during the land run.
他是一位来自堪萨斯州、受过高等教育的律师，是一个非常有思想和正派的人，他不赞成作弊派系和他们的土地阴谋。所以他着手试图在这个新城市的混乱中建立一些秩序。所以，在“哦，乔，这是你的骡子”之后，在第一天混乱之后，
He was a hyper-educated lawyer from Kansas, who was this very high-minded and decent guy who did not approve of the cheater faction and their land schemes. So he said about trying to create some order in the chaos of this new city. So after Ojo, here's your mule, after the chaos of that first day,
每个人都醒了，所有能睡着的人。他们环顾四周，意识到，天哪，这个地方一团糟。在这些私人财产之间没有空间容纳一条小巷。安杰洛·斯科特是站出来说“好吧，让我们解决这个问题”的人之一。他在第二天，实际上给三个孩子发了三个铃铛，把他们放在
everybody wakes up, everyone who's been able to sleep. And they look around and they realize, oh my gosh, this place is a mess. There's no room to fit an alley between these private properties. And Angela Scott is one of the people who steps up and says, well, let's figure this out. And he gives, actually on the second day, he hands out three bells to three kids and puts them on
小马上，让他们在俄克拉荷马城到处骑行，摇着铃铛说：“来参加城镇大会。”成千上万的人来了，安杰洛·斯科特站上一个木箱，向大家说明了情况。他说：“听着，我们现在的处境是这样的。我们的城镇是一片混乱。我们有一派人试图通过作弊来强加秩序。”他说这个地方的讽刺之处在于，如果他们采用了作弊者的城市规划，他们本可以获得绝对的和平，但这将是建立在
little horses and sends them riding all around Oklahoma City, ringing their bells and saying, come to a big town meeting. And thousands of people come and Angelelo Scott steps up onto this wooden crate and he kind of lays it out for everybody. He says, listen, here's where we are. Our town is chaos. We have one faction of people who are trying to impose order on it by cheating. And he says one of the ironies of the places that they could have had absolute peace if they had adopted this, you know, the cheaters planned for the city, but it would have been on the
绝对欺诈的基础上。所以他们必须想出其他方法来做。于是安杰洛·斯科特帮助组织了一次选举，成立了一个公民委员会。该委员会的工作是走遍整个城镇，裁决每一个地块，弄清楚谁可以留下，谁必须离开，哪些土地需要被征用并变成街道、小巷和公共空间。这就像是即兴的、临时的城市规划。所以他们逐个地块地工作，一直向北推进，直到到达作弊者城镇部分的南缘，在那里等着他们的是拿着温彻斯特步枪的人，他们说：“你在下面做那些事没问题，但我认为你最好别动这部分城镇。”这本可能是城市陷入内战的时刻，但相反，
basis of absolute fraud. So they have to figure out some other way to do it. And so Angelos Scott helps organize an election in which a Citizens Committee comes together. The job of that committee is to go around the whole town, adjudicating every lot, figuring out who can stay and who can go and what land needs to be seized and turn to streets and alleys and public spaces. It's like this ad hoc on the fly town planning. And so they went lot by lot by lot and worked their way north until they reached the southern edge of the Cheaters part of town, and waiting for them there were men holding Winchester rifles who said That's fine that you've done that down there, but I think you better leave this part of town alone This could have been the moment where the city teetered into civil war, but instead
城市陷入了内战。但相反，安杰洛·斯科特组织了另一次群众大会，他们提出了一个妥协方案。所以最后，他们不得不做一些对安杰洛·斯科特这样的人和许多人来说非常令人厌恶的事情，但这是在不发生暴力冲突的情况下将城市缝合在一起的唯一方法。所以他们所做的是这两个不同的计划，
the city teetered into civil war. But instead, Angelo Scott organized another mass meeting and they came up with a compromise plan. So in the end, they had to do something that was really abhorrent to someone like Angelo Scott and to a lot of people, but it was the only way to kind of stitch the city together without actually breaking into violence. So what they did was these two different plans,
南部的公民委员会计划和北部的繁荣者计划，调和它们的部分问题在于它们是以略微不同的角度铺设的。这意味着即使他们试图将城镇的这两个部分缝合在一起，也会非常困难，
the Citizens Committee plan down south, and the boomers plan up north, part of the problem of reconciling them was that they had been laid out at slightly different angles. This meant that even if they tried to stitch these two parts of town together, it would be very difficult,
因为街道无法对齐。所以他们达成的妥协是建造他们所谓的“慢跑路”（jogs），也就是连接两个不同街道网格的斜向街道。安杰洛·斯科特称它们为“无血冲突的伤疤”。所以本质上，想象一下走在一条街上，然后你来到一个十字路口，你必须向左转大约10英尺才能继续沿着那条街直走。
because the streets wouldn't match up. And so the compromise they settled on was to build what they called jogs, which are these kind of diagonal streets that connect the two different street grids. And Angela Scott called them the scars of a bloodless conflict. And so essentially just imagine walking down a street and then you come to an intersection and you have to turn kind of 10 feet to the left to keep walking straight along that street.
这对交通来说是一场噩梦。它永远导致交通堵塞。事实上，你仍然可以站在现代俄克拉荷马城街道网格的这些“慢跑路”上。它们还没有从街道网格中被抹平。令人惊奇的是，直到今天你仍然可以看到它。人们知道为什么俄克拉荷马城是这个样子吗？我想大多数人不知道，可能不知道。
It was a nightmare for traffic. It caused traffic jams forever. And in fact, you can still go stand on these jogs in the modern Oklahoma City street grid. They have not been ironed out of the street grid. It's amazing that you can still see it to this day. Do people know why it is the way it is in Oklahoma City? I think most people don't, probably no.
这只是他们时髦的小市中心。休息回来后，我们将与萨姆·安德森谈谈他整个职业生涯中最喜欢的科研发现。我想我可以写800本书，再也不会有像“邦戈行动”这样令人惊奇和不可思议的发现，所以我很高兴告诉你“邦戈行动”的故事。请留下来。所以如果你还记得最初带萨姆·安德森去俄克拉荷马城的事情，那不是土地大抢购的历史。
It's just kind of their funky little downtown. When we come back after the break, we're going to talk with Sam Anderson about his favorite research discovery of his entire career. I think I could write 800 books and never make another discovery as amazing and improbable as Operation Bongo, so I'd be delighted to tell you the story of Operation Bongo. Stay with us. So if you remember the thing that took Sam Anderson to Oklahoma City to begin with, it wasn't the history of the land run.
而是一支篮球队，俄克拉荷马城雷霆队。几十年来，俄克拉荷马城一直不被认为是可以支持职业运动队的城市。然而突然间，在2008年，它拥有了这支NBA篮球队，而它获得球队的方式是从西雅图抢来的。所以俄克拉荷马城雷霆队曾经是一支伟大的经典NBA球队，叫西雅图超音速队。有着可爱的绿色和黄色制服，多年来还有一些伟大的超级巨星球员。
It was a basketball team, the Oklahoma City Thunder. For many decades, Oklahoma City had not been considered the kind of city that could support a major pro sports team. And yet suddenly, in 2008, it had this NBA basketball team and the way it got it was by taking it from Seattle. So the Oklahoma City Thunder used to be this great classic NBA franchise called the Seattle Super Sonics. With these lovely green and yellow uniforms and some great superstar players over the years.
所以我必须写下这段将职业球队从一个城市带到另一个城市的历史。在写作过程中，我产生了一个疑问，好吧，为什么西雅图超音速队叫这个名字？我是看着这支球队长大的，但我从未想过质疑这个名字。所以我开始研究，好吧，这个名字从何而来？这让我陷入了一个相当深的兔子洞。
And so I had to write this history of the taking of a professional team from one city to another. And in the course of writing that, the question occurred to me, well, why are the Seattle SuperSonics called that? I grew up with this team, but I never thought to question the name. So I started researching, well, where did this name come from? And this led me down quite a rabbit hole.
事实证明，西雅图在20世纪60年代获得了篮球队，恰好是在美国试图启动其新的、具有未来感、改变世界的商业超音速飞行计划的同一时刻。当时的想法是飞机将以超过音速的速度在世界各地飞行。总部位于西雅图的波音公司处于许多此类发展的中心。所以你有这个计划，超音速计划，你有一支全新的篮球队，在这一伟大的城市体育协同效应时刻，他们将篮球队命名为西雅图超音速队。所以那是一个不错的故事，我想，酷。然后我想到，好吧，等一下，美国的超音速计划发生了什么？
It turned out that Seattle had gotten its basketball team back in the 1960s, at exactly the same moment when the United States was trying to launch its new futuristic world-changing program of commercial supersonic flight. This was the idea that airplanes would zoom around the world traveling faster than the speed of sound. Boeing, which is based in Seattle, was at the center of a lot of that development. So you've got this program, the Supersonic's program, and you've got this brand new basketball team, and in this great moment of civic sports synergy, they named the basketball team, the Seattle Supersonics. So that was a neat story, and I thought, cool. And then it occurred to me, well, wait a second, what happened to the American Supersonic Program?
就像，我从未坐过超音速喷气式飞机。嗯，我想我认识的人也没有。所以为什么这没有发生？于是我开始深入那个兔子洞。这就是我发现“邦戈行动”的原因。所以如果你试图启动一个全国性的商业超音速飞行计划，每个人都将在几分钟或几小时内
Like, I've never flown in a supersonic jet. Um, I don't think anyone I know has either. So why did this not happen? So then I started down that rabbit hole. And this is what led me to Operation Bongo. So if you are trying to launch a nationwide program of supersonic commercial flight where everyone's gonna be whipping around the continent
在大陆和世界各地飞来飞去，那么你有很多事情要担心。有各种各样的工程问题。它非常昂贵，等等等等。除此之外，你还有一个非常严重的潜在公关问题，那就是当你突破音障时，众所周知，你会产生一种巨大的轰鸣声，从天空中隆隆作响。这就是音爆。这是空气分子实际上被喷气式飞机压碎的地方，
and the world in a matter of minutes or hours, then you have a lot of things to worry about. There's all kinds of engineering problems. It's very expensive, et cetera, et cetera. In addition to all of that, you have a very serious potential PR problem, which is when you break the sound barrier, famously, you create this gigantic roaring noise that comes rumbling down from the sky. It's a sonic boom. And it's where air molecules actually get crushed
然后当它们从喷气式飞机周围散开并再次膨胀时，它们会发出这种雷鸣般的声音。这实际上与产生雷声的机制完全相同。所以联邦航空局和波音公司不得不问自己，好吧，如果我们每天成千上万次地向美国公民倾泻震耳欲聋的音爆，每个人会不会疯掉。他们想，好吧，为了测试它，我们必须找到一个真正的美国城市作为这个计划的“小白鼠”。而在俄克拉荷马城，举起了手，说我们可以成为那个城市。
by the jet, and then as they kind of scatter away from the jet and expand again, they make this thunderous noise. It's actually exactly the same mechanism that makes thunder. So the FAA and Boeing had to ask themselves, well, if we are raining down cacophonous booms all over the citizens of the United States, thousands of times a day, is everyone going to go crazy. And they figured, well, in order to test it, we're going to have to find an actual American city to be a kind of guinea pig for this program. And in Oklahoma City, Ray's his hand, it said, we can be that city.
是的，我的下巴都掉地上了。我简直不敢相信。俄克拉荷马城举起了手。事实上，商会，也就是镇上这种商业权力的影子政府，举手说，是的，是的，选我们。他们将获得各种激励措施。
Yeah, that's my jaw hit the floor. I couldn't believe it. Oklahoma City raised his hand. In fact, the Chamber of Commerce, who's this kind of shadow government of business powers in the town, raised its hand and said, yes, yes, pick us. They would get all kinds of incentives.
他们将获得很多钱，可能最重要的是，机场那条一英里长的超音速跑道。所以一直试图作为城市过度成就的俄克拉荷马城，将突然处于全球超音速飞行新运动的领先地位。所以他们说，对我们做吧，对我们做吧。它没有经过投票。
They were gonna get a lot of money and probably most importantly, this mile long supersonic runway at the airport. So the Oklahoma City, which was always trying to over achieve as a city, would suddenly kind of be in pole position in this worldwide new movement of supersonic flight. So they said, do it to us, do it to us. It didn't go through a vote.
没有征求公民的意见。政府没有批准。市政府。他们只是说，选我们。联邦航空局说，好吧，让我们做吧。所以1964年2月，俄克拉荷马城的人民被惊醒了。清晨，一声突如其来的音爆，一声雷鸣，
No citizens were asked. The government didn't approve of it. The city government. They just said, pick us. And the FAA said, yeah, let's do it. So in 1964, in February, the people of Oklahoma City are awakened. First thing in the morning by a sonic boom that just comes out of nowhere, a thunder clap
在晴朗的天空中。而且，你知道，人们的房子在摇晃，玻璃在破碎等等，没人知道它从哪里来。那就是开始。这被正式称为“邦戈行动”。它计划进行六个月，每天有规律地进行八次音爆，一周之内就有
out of a nice clear sky. And, you know, there are people's houses are shaking and glasses are breaking and stuff like that, no one knows where it's coming from. And that was the beginning. And this was officially known as Operation Bongo. And it was set to go for six months with booms eight times a day on a regular schedule and within a week there were
超过600起公民向城市的正式投诉，因为这些音爆是一个真正的问题。我是说，有清单，有公布的对人们房屋造成的损害清单，就像，就像，你知道，石膏墙在开裂，吊扇掉下来砸伤了学校里的孩子。我是说，我和一个人谈过，他告诉我他的鱼缸爆炸了。所以这确实是一次强烈的体验。
over 600 official complaints to the city from citizens because these booms were a real problem I mean there are lists there are published lists of the damage that it did to people's houses and it's like It's like you it's like, you know, plaster walls were cracking, ceiling fans were falling out and injuring children at school. Like, I talked to somebody who told me his fish bowl exploded. So it was really an intense experience.
当然，他们不知道为什么会发生这种情况。所以，最后，市议会不得不弄清楚发生了什么，并对商会说，这必须停止。商会说，不，不，你不明白。这是我们成为美国大城市的机会，他们让它继续下去。它持续了六个月。复活节那天休息了一天，它把人们逼疯了。他们对公民进行了系统性的民意调查，询问他们关于天空中不断传来的末日轰鸣声的感受，
And of course, they didn't know why it was happening. And so, finally, the city council had to figure out what was going on and said to the Chamber of Commerce, this has to stop. And the Chamber said, no, no, you don't understand. This is our chance to become a major American city and they let it go on. It went on for six months. There was one day off on Easter And it drove the people nuts. They did this systematic polling of the citizens where they asked them all these questions about how they were feeling about the apocalyptic roaring coming from the sky constantly and Turns out people really hate it There and there's this heartbreaking official document published at the end of the experiment.
结果人们真的很讨厌它。实验结束时发布了一份令人心碎的官方文件。
It's full of graphs, all these graphs of the misery of the people of Oklahoma City, just kind of rising and rising and rising throughout the six month period. And it was so bad that by the end of it it killed the supersonic program. The Boeing never even built the prototypes for this thing. It was just unworkable.
它充满了图表，所有这些关于俄克拉荷马城人民痛苦的图表，在六个月的时间里不断上升。情况太糟糕了，以至于在结束时，它扼杀了超音速计划。波音公司甚至从未为这个东西制造原型机。它根本行不通。
It just couldn't happen on any large scale. So the people of Oklahoma City in the 1960s killed Seattle's supersonic program. And then 40 years later, killed the Seattle Super Sonics and turned them into the Oklahoma City Thunder. And I mean, it just, it sounds like the most made up thing of all time. I could not believe it when I discovered this.
它无法在任何大规模范围内实现。所以20世纪60年代的俄克拉荷马城人民扼杀了西雅图的超音速计划。然后40年后，扼杀了西雅图超音速队，并将他们变成了俄克拉荷马城雷霆队。我是说，这听起来像是史上最编造的事情。我发现这一点时简直不敢相信。
That's amazing. 99% Invisible Was Produced This Week by Delaney Hall, Mixed in Tech Production by Sharif Yusuf, Music by Sean Riel. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of the team is Avery Trufflement, Joe Rosenberg, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Lee, Terran Mazza, and me Roman Mars. The full title of same Anderson's book is Boomtown, the fantastical saga of Oklahoma City, its chaotic founding, its apocalyptic weather,
太神奇了。《99%隐形》本周由德莱尼·霍尔制作，谢里夫·优素福进行技术制作混音，肖恩·里尔配乐。凯蒂·明格尔是我们的高级制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括艾弗里·特拉弗尔门特、乔·罗森伯格、埃米特·菲茨杰拉德、薇薇安·李、泰兰·马扎，以及我罗曼·马尔斯。萨姆·安德森的书的全名是《繁荣之城：俄克拉荷马城的奇幻传奇，其混乱的建城、末日般的天气、
its pornoing to basketball team, and the dream of becoming a world-class metropolis. It is truly great, go get it. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco, and produced on Radio Row Row in beautiful, downtown, Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective
其抢来的篮球队，以及成为世界级大都市的梦想》。它真的很棒，去买吧。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市美丽的市中心Radio Row制作。《99%隐形》是来自PRX的Radio Topia的成员，这是一个极其独立的集体。
of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. You can find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99iotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. Run Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But I invite you to bask in all the glory of everything 99% invisible at 99PI.org. Radio TIPI.
播客界最具创新性的节目。你可以在 radiotopia.fm 找到它们。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并参与讨论。你可以在推特上关注我 Roman Mars 和本节目 99PI.org。我们也有 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit。但我邀请你尽情享受 99% Invisible 的一切精彩内容，请访问 99PI.org。Radio TIPI。
From P-R-X. from PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
来自 PRX。来自 PRX。本集暂无评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。